[Music]
I got 15 crowns for the yappy mutt
[Music]
that's enough to buy some new clothes
I'm saying
Lily's path was to be prepared by 60
women wearing gold crowns who'd fill the
river valleys with blood
doesn't rhyme
for good predictions rhyme
you smell of death and Destiny heroics
and heartbreak it's onion
a rare and intelligent creature you're a
dick
the balls balls I got from humans credit
where credit is due that whole reverse
psychology thing you did on them was
brilliant by the way kill me I'm ready
you were told to leave temeria oh come
on
these views
is this what happens when you get old
you get unbearably crotchety and
cantankerous actually I've always wanted
to know the witches ever retired yeah
when they slow and get killed come on
you must forgive me oh Lord this happens
all the time it's true he has the face
of a cat and a coward but truth be known
it was kicked in the balls by an ox as a
child what that's
true
at least when Phil evangel's blade
kissed my throat I didn't [ __ ] myself
which is all I can hope for you good
Lords and your final breath
a shitless death
but I doubt it how's my singing
it's like ordering a pie and fighting it
has no filling
the more likely it is to spread
he could die oh [ __ ] girl
yeah we won't let that happen
I thought you'd have fangs or horns or
something
I had them filed down
the sentence would be passed by the very
council members you attacked
it is sure to be death
I suppose there's one way of getting
some rest why on Earth would you enlist
the Major's help after my warning it's
as though you felt a Scorpio and a
prettier than a spider because of its
lovely tail you weren't exactly
forthcoming
and seriously you
my mother do you think I'd make a bad
one
definitely will you be joining me
my lady I would never degrade your honor
in such a way I had to break it to you
but that ship has sailed wrecked and
sunk to the bottom of the ocean out